eric dupond moretti est mise en examen
par les magistrats de la cour de justice
de la république c'est dans le cadre de
l'information judiciaire ouverte à son
encontre pour prise illégale d'intérêts
les juges s'interroge sur plusieurs
enquêtes administratives qui ont été
diligentées par le garde des sceaux
visant des magistrats qui s'occupait de
dossiers le concernant
lorsqu'il était avocat alors eric
dupond-moretti at il cherché à régler
ses comptes avec des magistrats
notamment ceux du parquet national
financiers grâce à son statut de
ministre
c'est en tout cas ce que pense deux
syndicats de magistrats et l'association
anticor qui ont porté plainte contre lui
les juges devront éclaircir cette
question pour le moment
la ligne de défense des avocats du
ministre est clair selon eux le garde
des sceaux n'a fait que suivre des
procédures lancées par nicole belloubet
qui l'a précédée il n'a fait que suivre
l'avis des services m christophe ingrain
son conseil a fait savoir qu'il allait
contester cette mise en examen est qu'il
déposerait une requête en nullité on les
écoute
le ministre de la justice était convoqué
pour être mis en examen sans surprise il
a été mis en examen
il ne lui a pas été expliqué les raisons
pour lesquelles la commission
d'instruction a considéré que les
indices graves et concordants étaient
réunies et justifier sa mise en examen
ce mépris pour ces droits s'inscrit dans
la suite des anomalies que nous avons
constaté dénoncé depuis le début de la
procédure
eric dupond moretti a réagi pour le
ministre les syndicats ont mené des
manoeuvres politiques afin d'obtenir un
nouveau garde des sceaux
alors eric dupond-moretti lé va-t-il
démissionner juste après l annonce de sa
mise en examen
jean castex le premier ministre a
défendu le garde des sceaux lui
renouvelant toute sa confiance
hier emmanuel macron interrogées a
expliqué que le garde des sceaux avait
les mêmes droits que tous les
justiciables celui de la présomption
d'innocence et de pouvoir défendre les
droits qui sont les siens
donc pour le moment eric dupond moretti
est toujours appuyé par le gouvernement
en revanche dans l'opposition cette
annonce a fait l'effet d'une tornade
pour un ministre déjà contesté par les
féministes les sénateurs sociale
c'était le secrétaire national de lv
julien bayou premier à réagir ont déjà
appelé à sa démission